well Hillary Clinton's newest campaign
ads criticizing Donald Trump's business
ties to Russia Republican candidate as
many fans in that country starting with
the president Charlie d'Agata went to
Moscow to meet another front fan with a
huge following of his own
I also found someone who's paid a price
for standing up to Russians president
charlie is with us now from London good
morning good morning well not since the
Cold War has Russia played a sense such
a central role in American elections and
everybody over there is buzzing about it
too and as far as celebrity endorsements
go few come quite like this one of
Donald Trump's biggest fans is also one
of Russia's biggest stars i'ma just it
singer
okay sinking number one Philipp Kirkorov
zwei died enthusiasm for the Republican
candidate goes back 22 years when Kyra
performed at Trump's Taj Mahal casino in
Atlantic City
Trump dubbed him the Michael Jackson of
Russia and the bromance has been going
strong ever since I hope that's when the
Donald will be President our
relationship will be much much closer
and all American people finally
understand understood understood
understand understood that's Russia's
Russia is a great country Russian people
is a great people that mutual admiration
goes both ways Donald Trump has said
that he would cut back u.s. involvement
in NATO and his heaped praise on Russian
President Vladimir Putin calling him a
strong leader Putin has made clear his
preference for a president Trump White
House but there are far more sinister
accusations of collusion Russia stands
accused of hacking the Democratic
Party's email server I'm Hillary Clinton
and I approve and the Clinton campaign
is started running new ads that calling
to questioned Trump's financial ties in
Russia and how they could impact
decisions on national security while
former Russian opposition member Dmitri
good cough says Trump's admiration of
Putin is at the very least misguided is
not strong because his afraid of
participating in debates he's afraid of
fair elections he's afraid of being
removed and losing control I think it's
not the position of strong leader and he
says Putin has an easy way of silencing
any serious opposition I'm back to
participate in the TV discussion you're
banned from going on television yes I'm
banned from going to the television now
just think about that during tonight's
TV debate the American election is
getting lots of coverage from Kremlin
back channels and newspapers no prizes
for guessing who's they
as the favorite Nora all right Charlie
thank you so much